now you have said turning 50 was more
liberating and easier for you than 40.
why is that you know I think in
retrospect I was worried about all of
those things that society makes you
worry about you know kind of losing your
viability and your Youth and especially
for somebody like me who had made my
living you know with my face and like
what does this mean and am I going to be
put out to pasture and everybody's sort
of inferring that I'm going to be put
out to pasture
so it was a very hard birthday for me in
that way because I felt like well is it
over part of it was that I was you know
in the successful movie franchise at the
time the Iron Man the
um you know Avengers and all of that but
you know at the same time people are
saying are you worried you're not going
to get cast in a movie anymore now that
you're turning 40 so that gave me a lot
of anxiety and then you know turning 50
just felt so awesome and I was worried I
was going to have another nervous
breakdown a worse one do you just have
earmuffs to the outside perspectives now
and the opinions that are unnecessary
yeah it's really interesting it's like
these opinions now I think when I was
younger I would hear them and they would
kind of hit my nervous system and now
I'm like I don't really give up yeah
gwyneth's giving new meaning to the
phrase aging gracefully the Goof goddess
and Mom of two has even figured out how
to stay friends with famous exes like
Brad Pitt he recently sat down with her
for a goof q a have you guys always
stayed friends Through The Years in
touch when we first broke up we weren't
friends for a while and then we sort of
found our way back probably about I
don't know 18 or 19 years ago I adore
him he's an amazing person and I love
him I'm a big fan what does your husband
Brad think of the friendship with Brad
my husband is probably like the least
judgmental
most secure man in our relationship so I
think he he totally respects and
probably one of the things that he likes
about me is that I believe in conscious
uncoupling
when my husband and I were dating we
started this tradition of me cooking him
breakfast every Saturday morning I got
to take out a cue out of your book with
these boyfriend breakfast is that what I
gotta start doing so for us it works
really well but you know try it out also
important to Gwyneth health and fitness
she built a reported 250 million dollar
Empire around it and has the home Spa to
prove it you know I'm into Wellness so I
feel like it's Justified maybe I can
write it off as a business expensive but
you have a new partnership right now I
really love the product at copperfit I
started using the products and I
absolutely fell in love with them and
their
you know I'm like I'm always in my
compression socks on an airplane I use
the gloves a lot for my hands I want to
do a quick game really quick so a little
bit of rapid fire but really just the
first thing that comes to your mind when
you hear these topics the first one
Fitness empowerment sex
uh necessary
aging not scary marriage
um dreamy last one regrets
many but I wouldn't change them
[Music]
foreign